why does still flamingo wear glasses
does he have sensitive eyes maybe a bold
fashion statement
or is there some other meaning behind
them that connect to his complex
character
on a much deeper level than you might
have originally thought
in this video we will explore who
doflamingo
truly is at heart what his conflict with
luffy
means for the story and what makes him
one of the
most iconic antagonists in the entire
series
oh yeah and before we get into it if you
haven't subscribed to the channel yet
make sure to hit that big red button
below this video
doflamingo is a special antagonist in
the story
for a number of reasons his unusually
early introduction to the story
the fantastic and clever ways that he
uses his devil fruit his congress hockey
as well as his eccentric appearance are
just the tip of the iceberg here
because i believe that he's actually the
most
complex villain in the story so far
[Music]
doflamingo is a former celestial dragon
who has been
locked out of paradise giving him this
sort of backstory was a fantastic
move by oda as it ties his chaotic and
evil nature
together with one of the major
antagonistic forces of the story
doflamingo is not just evil for evil
sake
he's the tragic result of the unjust
world order
created by those around him his entire
childhood
doflamingo grew up under the ideology
that as a world noble
he was practically a god having
people serve at his will and drooling
over them with absolute control and
power
was not only an idea but something that
constituted everyday life in marijuana
and yet when his father decided to leave
this world of perverted excess
egotism and exploitation behind he was
suddenly confronted with the harsh
reality
of the real world where there were no
more slaves to do the work
and satisfy his every desire
in fact it was the exact opposite
hated for their heritage his family was
prosecuted by the commoners
being forced to go into hiding and lift
off garbage eventually
his mother succumbed to illness finally
one day together with his father homing
and his brother corazon
he was lynched by an angry mob of
commoners that had suffered under the
hand of the tenryuubito
this sudden transition from one extreme
into the other
traumatized and broke the young boy who
until then had known nothing but
pleasure
and entitlement for his entire life and
interestingly enough well this tragic
experience brought out the very best in
his brother corazon
[Music]
it brought out the very worst in himself
[Music]
a wonderful example of nature versus
nurture i believe
and so maybe in the end the decisive
factor between the two brothers
contrasting developments
was that rosinate was able to show and
share his emotions and pain
laughing crying and suffering side by
side with their parents
doflamingo meanwhile could never really
show his true feelings or
connect to them on a human level and
thus ended up projecting
all of his hate fear and pain on his
family
being thrown into misery through the
well-meaning but
terribly naive decision of his father to
try and live a normal life
he felt betrayed ultimately covering his
deep
emotional wounds and sudden lack of
self-confidence
with rage and the sense of importance
that he'd been spoon-fed his entire life
finally when his traumatizing experience
with villages was added to this
already quite toxic brew of emotions
doflamingo
snapped and i believe that it was at
this point
that he truly gave into evil and as a
result
executed his father this tragic past
results in one of my absolute favorite
speeches of the show
as chance would have it in this moment
of deepest darkness
he was discovered by none other than
treble who instead of showing him
care and love once again hailed him as
king and as superior to all others
filling the hole in his chest with even
more ideas of power and greatness
and being handed the tools to act on
them
doffy started to develop into the cruel
and manipulative villain that luffy
encounters on dressrosa
betrayed from all sides by his family
by the nobles and by the people he had
seen just
how cruel this world truly was and
realized that it needed to be reborn
in his message that is of course
however his lack of self-confidence and
true love
would never allow for that and so while
he loves nothing more than presenting
himself
as a messenger of chaos and destruction
to the world at large
chaos is a ladder in reality
we find out that he is a total control
freak in every sense of the word
desperate to literally try and pull all
the strings
from behind the scenes
he needs to be the puppeteer that has
full power over whatever is going on in
a small world
and this is exactly the reason why
betrayal and disloyalty
is the worst possible thing for him as
we can see with corazon
[Music]
and law
all of this can also be seen really well
in the relationship he has with his
family
while like a real dawn family seems to
be incredibly important to him
his relationship to his crew is quite
screwed
there's definitely no doubt that he does
seem to care for them to a certain
extent
as we can see after virgos and monet's
death or at the lengths that he went to
to protect baby five
however the things that matter most to
him are absolute loyalty and dedication
and so while it might paint him to
sacrifice one of his family members
he will do so to reach his goal
after all he is a king a god
who stands above everyone else his will
has
priority
[Music]
in many ways luffy and doflamingo are
two sides of the same coin
just like doffy luffy also strongly
values the wild patchwork family that he
has gathered around him
and those close to him however
never in his wildest dreams would luffy
put his own ambition
over that of his crew nor sacrifice even
a single one of them for
any of his goals because the straw hats
other than the donkey hot pirates are a
crucial part of his ambitions to begin
with
and not just pawns to be used it's
one of the major underlying messages of
the story
it doesn't really matter what type of
values you hold
but just how you act on them in the
world
[Music]
feels like he's entitled to be king and
stand above everyone else
he's just taken what is rightfully his
through poor strength and power of will
luffy meanwhile
also is convinced that he can become
pirate king and
takes whatever he wants and he does so
by pure strength and willpower as well
however where the two of them
fundamentally differ from each other
is in their incentive doffy wants to
rule and control
others and fill the gaping hole in his
heart by seeking the ultimate form of
attention
luffy on the other hand simply wants to
be
free
[Music]
do flamingos nakamura serve him while
luffy's crew are his equals
each with dreams and ambitions of their
own
dophi has subordinates and business
partners that want a piece of the cake
while luffy has friends and allies and
people that trust and believe in him
and genuinely wants him to succeed and
be happy
they give luffy purpose and together
guide him towards the right path
helping and fighting for his friends is
what got luffy this far
in the first place at first it was
shanks who inspired his dream
then it was the love and pain that he
shared with his brothers
that made him fight for his dream in
earnest
and finally it was his crew that helps
him do the impossible and
defy the world to reach their dreams
together
all of them believing in him but none of
them going easy on him
doffy never had that corrupted by the
perverse ideology of the nobles
and maybe also cursed by his nature he
never had the capability of laughing and
crying with his family
as for his executives they never really
gave him anything real to fight and
strive for
they just told him that he was entitled
to be king and rule overall
anyway and as they like to say it's very
lonely
alone at the top
this pattern just keeps going and going
the deeper you dig
doffy despises the tendril beto and
wants to tear down the old world for
all the injustice and pain that it has
inflicted on him
luffy also despises the nobles and the
world governments
however because of what they've done to
his friends not to him
and while dophie envisions a new world
where only the strong will make the cuts
ironically enough he is the one holding
the old world together
by pulling the strings from the
underworld working with both the world
government
and the yonko to secure his position
only through his defeat by luffy is the
world thrown into real chaos
as doffy is the very first person not to
make the cut for this new world order
this deep irony makes him one of the
most
tragic characters in the story i believe
and so
this already brings me to the main point
of this video
that i think many people overlook when
it comes to doflamingo's character
[Music]
you see based on all that we've
discussed so far
i believe that the biggest irony of the
entire dressrosa arc
was the bird cage and all of the other
bird symbolism
united in a man that oda literally named
doflamingo because
he is literally a fragile and exotic
bird that is
caged himself let me explain
in many ways doflamingo has always been
the puppet of others
never really having any say or control
over his own life
his dreams or his destiny the true
tragedy here however
was that he never saw the strings
himself
he never really heard the commands to
follow his purpose
never saw the walls raised around him
isolating him from the worlds
never felt the push of other people
using him for their own interests
but he always followed through on them
the celestial dragons told him to behave
like a god
his father made him a tone for his own
bad conscience and experience
hell then the world nobles treated him
like an outcast pushing him away
treble and the other executives told him
to behave like a king and strive for
power once more
and finally he was working for the
government and kaido
keeping control over his own small
island where he would be able to
terranize the people and play gods
while working for other people's dreams
and ambitions
not once in his entire life did dofie
have the chance to learn
who he truly is and what he truly wants
in life
always being a slave to the ideals of
others
this is why luffy will become king of
the pirates
and why dovey never had a chance to play
the game in the first place
because to become pirate king and truly
change the world you need one thing
above all
freedom
and so once again it took luffy to
literally
break the birdcage that held this rare
and exotic flamingo his entire life
by shattering all the expectations and
stories about being special
that he'd been fed his entire life and
that had dictated his
every move he wanted to be the puppet
master
but ended up being the puppets he was
supposed to be a bird that could fly
freely
but in the end was locked in a cage for
his entire life
and so i think this is why in his battle
with luffy
dophie is a man with no love no freedom
and no dream of his own and as a result
has
nothing left to lose and so by
completely destroying him and everything
he has worked for
as he so often does luffy does not only
free dress rosa
but doflamingo as well the moment
his cage crumbles and falls dovie
finally escapes the prison he had built
himself unknowingly
and so while we don't know the original
reason that doflamingo started wearing
glasses in the first place
the fact that he was wearing shades his
entire life
really symbolizes well the shadow under
which he had lived since
his childhood and luffy finally
breaking these glasses as he beats
dophie right into the ground
finally gives him a glimpse into the
light
the only question that remains is
whether he will actually notice
[Music]
i think what doflamingo's character
really is supposed to show us
is just how cruel toxic and unjust the
world is under the rule of the tendrio
beto
and how the system that the world
government has created produces
true despair and evil and so
doflamingo and the entire dressrosa arc
ultimately present to us the true nature
of the world in miniature
in the end doflamingo is just another
tragic victim of the system and luffy is
once again the one that works to abolish
it
and so i genuinely believe that it's all
of these complex layers that are woven
into doflamingo's character
that make him one of the most
interesting and
fascinating villains in anime
there is also another aspect to
doflamingo's character
that i found incredibly interesting that
however didn't really fit into the
context of this video
the similarities between him and
crocodile
and so i decided to make a small bonus
video on the topic that you can watch
on the left here or if you already want
to look to the next villain in the story
you can learn how katakuri was able to
win his fight against luffy
on the right thanks guys peace